we now have a lot of experience taking
limits of a function so if i'm taking
the limit of f of x we're going to think
about what does f x approach as x
approaches some value a
and this would be equal to some limit
now everything we've done up till now is
where a is a finite value but when you
look at the graph of the function f
right over here you see something
interesting happens
as x gets larger and larger it looks
like our function f
is getting closer and closer to 2. it
looks like we have a horizontal
asymptote at y equals 2.
similarly as x gets more and more
negative it also seems like we have a
horizontal asymptote at y equals 2.
so is there some type of notation we can
use to think about what is the graph
approaching as x gets much larger or as
x gets smaller and smaller and the
answer there is limits at infinity so if
we want to think about what is this
graph what is this function approaching
as x gets larger and larger we can think
about the limit
of f of x
as x approaches positive infinity
so that's the notation and i'm not going
to give you the formal definition of
this right now there in future videos we
might do that but it's this idea as x
gets larger and larger and larger does
it look like that our function is
approaching some finite value that we
have a horizontal asymptote there and in
this situation it looks like it is it
looks like it's approaching the value 2.
and for this particular function the
limit
of f of x
as x approaches negative infinity also
looks like it is approaching 2. this is
not always going to be the same you
could have a situation maybe we had you
could have another function so let me
draw a little horizontal asymptote right
over here
you could imagine a function that looks
like this
so i'm going to do it like that and
maybe does something wacky
like this
and it comes down and it does something
here our limit as x approaches infinity
is still 2 but our limit as x approaches
negative infinity right over here would
be negative 2. and of course there's
many situations where as you approach
infinity or negative infinity you aren't
actually approaching some finite value
you don't have a horizontal asymptote
but the whole point of this video is
just to make you familiar with this
notation and limits at infinity or you
could say limits at negative infinity
they have a different formal definition
than some of the limits that we've
looked at in the past where we're
approaching a finite value but
intuitively they make sense that these
are indeed limits